si le passé laisse ses traces dans le
paysage sont intéressés lecture peuvent
devenir difficiles sans un travail de
fond la réhabilitation entreprises dans
le centre ancien d'orléans est
ambitieuse loin d'un simple
dépoussiérage laurent mazuy experts du
patrimoine bâti urbain et paysager a
coordonné ce projet pour la ville on se
trouve en fait dans l'hyper centre
d'orléans dans un secteur qui à
l'origine était clos par la première
enceinte et qui correspond à peu près à
25 hectares de construction d'histoire
et d'empilement d'architecturé c'est un
projet global est avant tout une
requalification de l'espace public donc
un travail sur les chaussées les fameux
pavé blanc les pavés de souppes sur
loing
et puis des ravalements de façade mais
aussi un plan lumière une redistribution
de la lumière autant touristique que
public
le premier paramètre c'est de savoir ce
que l'on veut faire
hier soir un simple toilettage des
façades 1 ou de l'espace public ou de
recréer un espace avec en fondant une
autre mythologie à notre rapport à
l'histoire aux paysages 800 façades ont
été ainsi rénovés dont les plus
anciennes datant du xvème siècle période
où les bâtis antérieures ont été effacé
du paysage et maisons sont plus
anciennes sont dus 13/14 ans pierre en
pierre de taille ou en pente proie comme
celle ci de 13 cents 94 mais c'est assez
rare puisqu'en fait on a une grande
campagne à la fin du xvème siècle
deux restent hors d'europe de
reconstruction pas de restauration où
pratiquement une grande partie du
centre-ville est entièrement rebâtie
faut s'imaginer le chantier que ça
pouvait être
il
et
oui
laurent en lien avec les architectes des
bâtiments de france proposent les
restaurations première étape
l'expertisé quand le 38 est tombée on
voit qu apparaît tout un ensemble de
vestiges de fragments qu'il convient
d'observer domaine dans le born ordre
chronologique
on a d'abord les enduits anciens entre
les poutres de bois qui sont conservés
on a de la peinture sur les pans de bois
on voit les murs mitoyens en pierre avec
des traces de couleur bien tout un
ensemble d'informations et par un jeu
tout simplement de dessous dessus dans
l'observation des procédures de
construction de la façade on arrive à
restituer sa chronologie orléans est
aussi bâti en pierre de taille
parmi ses fleurons ces deux maisons de
commerçants construite en 15 100 9 et 15
144 la face à la plus ouvre âgé était
très abîmé mais avec le parement
apparent une sculpture apparente par
contre l'autre façade la maison dite de
l'ours était entièrement enduite y
compris les sculptures qui encadre les
fenêtres on ne voyait absolument rien et
donc quand on a un est libéré fait
tomber l'enduit il a voulu reprendre
tout le parement re nettoyer les
sculptures les faire réapparaître et
toutes les sculptures qui viennent en
saillie ont été retaillée pour la
circonstance
la majorité des façades ont été dès
l'origine ou au fil du temps enduite
d'un mélange sablé show offrant une
tonalité sobre et beaucoup de nuances
c'est uniquement la nature du sable qui
permet de teintes et la manière de
l'appliquer
on prend du sable de loi ou du loir ce
qui donne un ton jaune ou blanc et si
comme on voit dans ces deux façades
il est légèrement brossé on a
relativement peu de laitance de blanc
qui remonte à la surface si on le sert à
la truelle ou à l'eponge la laitance
vanité donc c'est très très subtil mais
toutes les façades sont différenciés à
part des toutes petites dimanche soit
des textures soit de couleur
la différence c'est aussi cette
soixantaine de bâtiments à pans de bois
visible une technique qui a traversé les
époques
car elle permet une construction rapide
évolutive
la première époque c'est le plus vieux
pont de bois très 194 pendent doit
trouver à orléans avec ses grandes croix
de saint-andré ces croix de saint-andré
un peu plus loin on voit bien qu'elles
sont plus petites et elles viennent
faire un effet décoratif
et puis après le pont de bois gris avec
ses poutres verticale à la fin du xvième
siècle les pans de bois aux couleurs
vives sont dans cette réhabilitation
ce qui est le plus visible est peut-être
le plus atypique et c'est un effet de
mode
est ce une technique héritée du passé
paysage a posé la question à laurent
mazuy réponse la semaine prochaine